[Music]
most of us said that feel maybe they're
not helping enough and in this way we
can at least say thank you so much for
all of this is your doing you don't have
to have any Talent
just simple gesture but effective I just
posted something on my social media
channels put it on my whatsapp truth was
picked up within 24 hours by the Sussex
Royal and then Victoria Beckham now like
these people with such a huge following
and being willing to you have to lend
their reach for something as there's no
[Applause]
doctors coming out if the hospital
clapping it's one another that was yeah
what moves me most but seeing pictures
of people out of windows and then the
old like in high rises and you hear all
that sounds and you basically just hear
that emotion coming through that isn't
yeah that moves me a lot
this crisis hits everybody it is a that
doesn't look at who you are how much
money you have in a bank just hates
everybody even the Prime Minister oh
it's a bit on the late ID which you can
still that kids can be in their PJs help
clapping and then because that it is for
them such a strange time as well so yeah
what can we do to to make it just a
little less heavy for them or negative
for them everybody says hello and wave
now I know the names of my name is what
I didn't know before and it's at least
the feeling of community I really hope
that we are now aware how much you mean
to us and how important your role is and
that you are the backbone of our society
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]